[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis einzigen guten abend an meiner
seite mit dem sport norbert jemand schön
genannt doch von mir und wir schauen
heute ausführlich auf die politischen
folgen der landtagswahl in
nordrhein-westfalen
aufbruch und katerstimmung in berlin
nach der nrw-wahl triumphiert die union
die ampel partner spd und fdp hadern mit
dem schlechten ergebnis
symbolbild in der propaganda schlacht
die ukraine zeigt soldaten die russische
einheiten offenbar bis zur grenze
zurückgedrängt haben insgesamt aber
bleibt der osten umkämpft
hitze stürme und borkenkäfer in den
deutschen wäldern geht nur noch jeder
fünfte baum als gesund
am tag nach der landtagswahl in
nordrhein westfalen sehen sich cdu und
grüne im aufwind das erste mal könnte es
in dem bundesland ein schwarz grünes
bündnis geben spd und fdp sind dabei
ihre verluste zu verdauen was das auch
für die ampel koalition im bund bedeutet
darauf schauen wir gleich erst einmal
blicken wir auf das vorläufige amtliche
ergebnis
klar stärkste kraft die cdu mit 35,7
prozent
28 punkte mehr als 20 17 verluste für
die spd
26,7 minus 4,6 rekordzuwachs bei den
grünen 18 2% plus 11,8 die fdp bricht
einer 5,9 prozent die fdp 5 4 prozent
die linke 2,1 prozent schauen wir auf
die möglichen koalition schwarz-grün mit
einer mehrheit von 115 sitzen oder eine
ampel mit 107 sitzen die wahlbeteiligung
war mit 55 5 prozent historisch niedrig
die cdu und der relativ neuer parteichef
führen sich auch bundesweit wieder
obenauf tanzen aus berlin berichtet
friedrich merz musste schmunzeln auf die
frage ob es nun einen märz effekt
gegeben habe bei der landtagswahl
gestern in nrw wäre sie verloren
gegangen so märz hätten sich viele davon
gesprochen insofern gibt es sicherlich
effekte aber ich will sie weder
überbewerten noch unterbewertet in
erster linie war dies eine landtagswahl
und diese landtagswahl hat hendrik wüst
gewonnen und wir haben ihm erfolgreich
dabei geholfen sehr ähnlich die wertung
von wüst selbst er dankte für die
unterstützung auch märz persönlichen
einsatz eine klare koalitionsaussage mit
blick auf nrw treffen der es auch heute
nicht nur so viel wenn man sich die
zahlen anschaut sieht man es gibt zwei
wahlgewinner und wenn wir das alle jetzt
mal nach einer nacht drüber schlafen mit
respekt und anstand zu kenntnis nehmen
ergeben sich daraus glaube ich ein paar
leitplanken für die gespräche aber ich
sage es noch mal gerne werde auf alle
demokratischen im landtag vertretenen
parteien zugehen binnen einer woche gibt
es nun mit daniel günther und henrik 2
im amt bestätigt die
cdu-ministerpräsidenten beide jung beide
potenzielle kanzlerkandidaten ist bei
der auch für einen anderen stil stünden
als märz was man hier entschieden zurück
wir sehen dass die cdu der krachend bei
der bundestagswahl verloren hatte den
dreh hinbekommen hat und das dank auch
einer sehr klaren führung aber auch
integrierenden führen und das ist auch
das was vielleicht viele überrascht bei
friedrich merz dass er die breite der
partei nicht nur diskutieren lässt
sondern auch mitnimmt mit blick auf die
spd gab es derweil oft und wortreich den
hinweis darauf dass die niederlage auch
mit dem kanzler nach hause gehe bei der
sich im wahlkampf energisch eingebracht
habe man nannte das hier den scholz
effekt
die cdu zu den wahlgewinnern die afg
dagegen zu den verlierern die
zerstrittene partei hat deutlich stimmen
eingebüßt die linke hat es nicht mal in
den landtag geschafft und eben auch zwei
der drei ampel parteien im bund sind
angeschlagen aus der wahl herausgekommen
aber es hapert über die aufarbeitung der
wahlergebnisse in der koalition
katerstimmung nennt man das wohl was sie
bei der spd am morgen danach verspüren
das schlechteste wahlergebnis in nrw
verschlägt den meisten die lust das auch
noch zu kommentieren
hinter verschlossenen türen wurde dann
geredet fazit anders als im
bundestagswahlkampf ist es nicht
gelungen den wählern in nrw zu
vermitteln wir kümmern uns zum beispiel
bei den explodierenden energie und
verbraucherpreisen wir haben zugelassen
dass zu viel über waffenlieferungen und
zu wenig über gestiegene
lebenshaltungskosten und zu wenig über
gestiegene energiepreise auch in der
kommunikation geredet wurde und das ist
eine der rückschlüsse die man auch aus
dem ergebnis gestern bei der
landtagswahl ziehen kann das für und
wider von waffenlieferungen habe wähler
vertrauen und damit stimmen gekostet so
die analyse der spd bei den grünen
wahlgewinnern ist das anders im
gegensatz zu den koalitionspartnern
profitieren sie auch von der arbeit
ihrer ministerinnen und minister in der
bundesregierung eine belastung für die
zusammenarbeit sei das aber nicht das
sind alles profis in allen drei parteien
und dementsprechend habe ich da
keinerlei sorgen wir werden zusammen
erfolgreich sein und werden zusammen die
probleme in diesem land lösen ob das die
fdp auch so sieht das satte minus von
6,7 prozent in nrw ist für den
parteichef auch eine gerechtigkeitsfrage
so habe die energiekosten pauschale die
nicht für rentner gelte der fdp etliche
stimmen gekostet es ist der
bundesregierung nicht gelungen die frage
der gerechtigkeit der energiepreis
pauschale befriedigend zu beantworten
die energiepreis pauschale war wie sie
wissen keine initiative der freien
demokraten sondern kam aus dem kreis der
koalitionspartnerinnen und
koalitionspartner die wahl in nrw hat
unterschiedliche auswirkungen auf die
ampel in berlin zwei verlierer eine
gewinnerin und die frage inwieweit das
das regierungshandeln künftig
beeinflussen wird
durch die nrw wahl also gestärkte grüne
geschwächte spd und fdp theo koll in
berlin wird es dadurch jetzt lauter
knirschen in der ampel koalition im bund
also davon ist auszugehen auf jeden fall
werden einige ampel listen versuchen
lauter wahrgenommen zu werden das gilt
vor allem natürlich für die liberalen
den die fdp hat zwar viele kämpfe
innerhalb der koalition geworden aber
dabei viele wähler verloren ausgerechnet
der liberalen chef lindner wird als
finanzminister mit den dramatisch
steigenden schulden verbunden was noch
nicht wirklich der politischen dna der
partei entspricht und auch ihrer wähler
und auch für den ausschluss der rentner
wir haben es eben gehört von der
energiepreis pauschale haben vor allem
die liberalen den politischen preis
bezahlt die spd dürfte sich ebenfalls
wieder stärker auf ihre kernklientel
konzentrieren wird aber zugleich vom
kanzler gedrängt für den
koalitionsfrieden viel einzustecken
wobei die grünen sich in der ampel gar
nicht weiter spreizen müssen denn die
haben mit der wahrscheinlicher schwarz
grünen koalition in nordrhein westfalen
künftig immer einen diskreten hinweis
auf eine alternative koalition zur hand
und in der cdu heißt es man habe jetzt
neben oder besser hinter friedrich merz
wieder eine führungsreserve einschätzung
von theo koll dankeschön
in nrw selbst sind die grünen so was wie
die königsmacher der landesvorstand
versammeln sich zur stunde in düsseldorf
um darüber zu beraten ob man schwarz
grün ansteuert oder ob man sich doch
eine ampel mit spd und fdp vorstellen
kann und das ganze beobachtet für uns
dort ferber dort haben die grünen schon
eine tendenz erkennen lassen
nein also beim reingehen gab es hier
kein tendenziell es sterbenswörtchen
aber die landesvorsitzende monat
neubauer hat heute noch einmal betont
dass man mit allen demokratischen
parteien reden werde also neben der cdu
auch mit der spd und der fdp und da
lautet die botschaft an die cdu also
wenn es mit schwarz grün nicht klappt
eine ampel wäre auch möglich hendrik
wüst weiß also dass er den grünen etwas
bieten muss um eine koalition zustande
zu bekommen die ihn dann zum
ministerpräsidenten wählt und die haben
grünen haben heute auch noch mal gesagt
dass es möglicherweise noch wege zu
gehen gebe in der tat sind die
positionen in einigen politikbereichen
energiepolitik oder auch innere
sicherheit doch recht weit auseinander
für die spd und die liberalen heißt es
abwarten bei der spd ihr mit einem
hoffnungsvollen judge vielleicht könnte
es doch noch für die ampel reichen heißt
es dort die liberalen sehr zurückhaltend
die sagen die zeichen stehen auf
schwarz-grün aber auch dort sie
schließen nichts aus also eine ampel ist
theoretisch auch möglich danke dort
ferber
und hintergründe und analysen zur wahl
in nordrhein westfalen auch darüber wo
die parteien jeweils zugelegt oder
verloren haben finden sie bei uns online
und in der zdf- heute
soweit zur wahl an dieser stelle
putins krieg gegen die ukraine führt zum
umdenken bei bisher neutral nationen
auch schweden vollzieht eine zeitenwende
ministerpräsidentin anders kündigte an
schweden werde die mitgliedschaft in der
nato beantragen die große mehrheit der
abgeordneten ist dafür schweden brauche
die sicherheitsgarantie des bündnisses
sagte die regierungschefin auch finnland
bindeglied werden russlands präsident
putin hat heute reagiert bei einem
treffen mit vertretern ehemaliger
sowjetrepubliken
eine unmittelbare bedrohung sei der
beitritt der beiden länder nicht sagte
er und warnte gleichzeitig wenn die
allianz dort auf rüste werde russland
reagieren
schauen wir in die ukraine dort
konzentrieren sich die russischen
angriffe vor allem auf den don bass aber
der vormarsch der stock gleichzeitig
gelingt des ukrainischen truppen
ortschaften zurückzuerobern in der nähe
von hf sollen sie bis an die russische
grenze vorgerückt sein alexandra vacano
fasst die entwicklung an der front
zusammen
wir haben es geschafft wir sind hier
sagt der ukrainische offizier neben dem
gelb-blauen grenzposten die brigade
hätte die staatsgrenze zurückerobert was
sich unabhängig nicht überprüfen lässt
die soldaten hätten in den vergangenen
wochen im nordosten des landes die
russischen einheiten zurückgedrängt
gebiete nördlich der stadt katif
zurückerobert heißt es von ukrainischer
seite
sprengung einer eisenbahnbrücke in der
region luhansk wir waren es sagen die
ukraine um die russen aufzuhalten denn
deren großes ziel seit wochen die
regionalhauptstadt sie werden etsc
einzukesseln von norden und von süden
das war auch der plan für donetsk hier
heute vereinzelt angriffe auch im süden
schlagen erneut russische raketen
eingetroffen die schwarzmeerstadt odessa
wieder einmal am tag 82 des krieges
besonders umkämpft ist in der ukraine
der zugang zum schwarzen meer die
südliche frontlinie verläuft zwischen
nikolajew und hessen gelingt der
russischen armee hier ein durchbruch
wäre die ukraine vom schwarzen meer
abgeschnitten aus dem dorf prix bußgeld
ukrainisch kontrolliert berichtet dara
hassanzadeh
wir sind auf dem weg zur front das dorf
prix buske seit tagen liegt es unter
russischem artilleriefeuer 3000 menschen
lebten hier die dorfkirche dem
patriarchat moskaus zugehörig nur eine
ikone zeugt noch von ihrer existenz
noch eine handvoll bewohner sind
geblieben trotz täglichem beschuss haben
sie angst
ja
nur verrückte haben keine angst
und ich bin kein dummkopf er ist bauer
sein hof und sein land das ist sein
leben wenn er ginge sagt er uns dann
würde er genau das verlieren sein leben
so gegen acht haben sie los gefeiert von
dort drüben nach darüber vier raketen
sind über mein dach geflogen
sie sind wirklich verrückt geworden wie
losgelassene kettenhunde
gestern wurde dieses haus getroffen die
bewohner hatten erst vor zwei tagen ihr
heim verlassen der krieg hier an der
südwest front es ist kein kampf soldat
gegen soldat sondern artillerie gegen
artillerie und die russische artillerie
schießt weiter
das dorf ist völlig zerbombt das zentrum
völlig zerstört und in unserer straße
das haus wurde auch geschossen
nur zwölf meter von nicola und seinem
sohn entfernt ein blindgänger er schlug
vor einer woche ein und ist inzwischen
entschärft von der ukrainischen armee
nachdem nordkorea vor wenigen tagen
überhaupt erst bekannt gegeben hat dass
es in dem land corona fälle gebe scheint
sich die lage jetzt rasant zu
verschaffen 50 menschen seien an die es
heißt fieber gestorben mehr als 1,2
millionen menschen erkrankt nordkorea
hat eines der schlechtesten
gesundheitssysteme der welt über die
pandemie in dem weitgehend isolierten
land gefälle
nordkoreas diktator kim jong un ist als
krisenmanager unterwegs besucht eine
apotheke die die staatliche propaganda
wohl extra für seinen auftritt
hergerichtet hat und selbst das reicht
dem großen führer nicht die apotheken
seien unzureichend für den virus
ausbruch ausgestattet kritisiert er die
straßen der hauptstadt pjöngjang sind
menschenleer die vielen desinfektions
teams können nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass nordkorea schlecht
auf den ausbruch vorbereitet ist
impfstoffe aus dem ausland hat das
abgeschottete land abgelehnt die
ratschläge im staatlichen fernsehen
wirken fast hilflos
schlafen sie genug trinken sie genug
essen sie leicht verdauliches und spülen
sie den mund mit salzwasser aus
das virus trifft auf ein bitterarmes und
ungeimpften land den meisten geht es bei
weitem nicht so gut wie der
vorzeigefamilie mit ihrem vorzeige
optimismus
ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir mit der
richtigen medizin das virus besiegen
können der virus ausbruch ist eine
katastrophe für das land der diktator
kim jong un hat sich entschieden dies
der welt zu offenbaren es könnte ein
hilferuf seien für medikamente und
impfstoffe
bisher allerdings hat nordkorea jegliche
hilfe abgelehnt
kim jong-un muss sich entscheiden ohne
hilfe vom ausland versinkt sein land
wohl im corona chaos
wieder nach deutschland seit monaten
streiten beschäftigte der kitas und in
der sozialarbeit für bessere
arbeitsbedingungen
auch heute wieder zum auftrag der wohl
entscheidenden verhandlungsrunde der
gewerkschaften fordern pauschal eine
höhere eingruppierung aller sozial und
erziehungsberufe unbezahlbar sagt die
arbeitgeberseite umsieht am ehesten
spielraum bei sozialarbeiter innen
sollte bis übermorgen keine einigung
stehen wollen die betroffenen die
streiks massiv ausweiten
wie krank ist unser wald und wie kann
man ihn widerstandsfähiger gegen die
klimakrise machen darüber berieten heute
die agrarministerinnen und minister von
bund und ländern denn das problem ist
riesig nach mehreren dürre jahren gelten
vier von fünf bäumen als krank fast fünf
prozent der gesamten waldfläche sind
abgestorben das liegt an trockenheit und
an borkenkäfern aber auch an früheren
entscheidungen der wald besitzerinnen
und besitzer so wachsen etwa auf rund
einem viertel der gesamtfläche die
eigentlich lukrativen aber auch
besonders anfälligen fichten jetzt geht
es um einen neuen wald luisa hoben und
hagen nicolas forstwirt cornelius meyer
stork hat in den vergangenen jahren fast
all seine fichten fällen müssen geld
verdienen konnte er mit ihnen nicht sie
waren vom borkenkäfer befallen oder
vertrocknet
gibt es natürlich in diesem wald einen
gravierenden ertragsausfall ja und der
wird also schon sich nicht nur auf die
nächste sondern sogar auf die
übernächste generation auswirken dieses
holz kann meyer stork nur noch als
schadholz verkaufen ist taugt nur als
industrieholz oder zur papierherstellung
so geht es auch anderen forstwirten von
den im vergangenen jahr bundesweit
geschlagenen 83 milliarden kubikmetern
holz waren 50 milliarden schadholz es
sei in den vergangenen drei jahren ein
schaden von 12,5 milliarden euro
entstanden so der deutsche
forstwirtschaftsrat nun sollen
waldbesitzer neue unterstützung bekommen
nach der heutigen agrarministerkonferenz
kündigte bundesagrarminister özdemir
einen neuen bundesweiten standard für
waldbewirtschaftung und finanzielle
hilfen an ein team wird es auf eine
ausgewogene balance zwischen den
anforderungen und biodiversität
klimaschutz und rohstoffversorgung im
rahmen eines verantwortungsvollen
waldmanagement ankommen die forstwirte
hoffen auf milliarden für einen neuen
wald doch die höhe und bedingungen der
staatshilfen sind noch unklar aber noch
in diesem jahr soll es losgehen
starke gewitter und unwetter zogen am
nachmittag über teile westdeutschlands
besonders heftig traf es gegen dänemark
teil so liefen in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler
zahlreiche keller voll straßen wurden
überflutet und es kam zu unfällen auch
für köln galt zeitweise eine
unwetterwarnung in kürzester zeit fielen
stellenweise bis zu 25 liter regen pro
quadratmeter
nun kommen wir zum sport und norbert da
haben die handballerinnen aus bietigheim
er ein grund zu feiern ja aber hallo
erstens ihren fünfzigsten sieg in serie
und zweitens den größten erfolg in ihrer
vereinsgeschichte die sg gewann gestern
abend in dänemark die european league
durch den klaren 31 20 erfolg beim final
four turnier gegen bieber
trainer markus gaugisch ist seit april
auch nationaltrainer der bietigheim
material ist für ihn so etwas wie ein
gütesiegel des deutschen frauenhandballs
nach dem glücklichen halbfinal sieg
gegen die dänen aus kaarst garantiert
dem finale eine starke defensive den
klaren erfolg gegen die gastgeberinnen
von haribo julia maidhof trifft zum 31
20 entstand die nächsten ziele sind
höher gesteckt
wir wollen in die champions league mit
dem meistertitel haben wir das geschafft
und sind froh dass wir dann da mitmachen
können
bietigheim holt den ersten großen
internationalen titel für ein deutsches
frauen handball team seit dem ehf cup
gewinnen des sc leipzig vor 30 jahren
mancity mit trainer pep guardiola macht
den zweikampf mit liverpool um die
englische fußball-meisterschaft noch mal
so richtig spannend denn die citizens
ließen bei west ham zwei punkte liegen
nach nur 2 rückstand kam city durch ein
eigentor zwar noch zum ausgleich
verschoss dann aber durch riad maries
einen elfer sollte liverpool morgens auf
händen gewinnen dann hätte city vor dem
letzten spieltag nur noch einen einzigen
punkt vorsprung
zwei deutsche basketballspieler stehen
in den nwa halbfinals daniel theis mit
dem boston celtics und maxi kleber mit
den dallas mavericks beide klubs setzten
sich im siebten spiel der zweiten
playoff runde durch spektakulär der
auswärtssieg der mavericks
luca den chip ist bei den navs der
überragende spieler in phoenix gelingen
den 23 jährigen slowenen insgesamt 35
punkte und zehn rebounds und denn nicht
selbst den korb sucht setzt er wie hier
den deutschen nationalspieler maxi
kleber seine mitspieler in szene
danach ist auch mitgereiste dirk
nowitzki kann stolz sein auf seine
nachfolger der die suns gelegentlich in
ihre einzelteile zerlegt nach diesem 123
zu 90 kantersieg beim titelverteidiger
treffen die mavs am mittwoch im
halbfinale auf die golden state warriors
was den frustriert abwandern phoenix
fans ziemlich egal sein dürfte
das glaube ich gerne bei der klatsche 90
so 123 g
allerdings wer heute früh aufgestanden
oder gar nicht erst ins bett gegangen
ist der wurde mit einem spektakel am
himmel belohnt eine totale
mondfinsternis wie hier in spanien kurz
vor der morgendämmerung schob sich der
vollmond für einige minuten in den
schatten
und mancher ort zu wie in den usa vettel
ich dabei der rötlich zum mond bevor er
hinter dem horizont verschwand
sieht schick aus auch heute nacht ziehen
schwere gewitter über uns hinweg worauf
sie sich gefasst machen müssen das
erfahren sie gleich von katja horne war
[Musik]
guten abend das wird eine turbulente
wetter woche auch wenn das erste
gewittertief dieser woche morgen schon
richtung südosten abziehen aber schon
heute gab es ja kräftige gewitter zum
teil mit enormen regenmengen bad
neuenahr ahrweiler kamen schon mehr als
40 liter regen pro quadratmeter herunter
und allein 32 von diesen litern allein
in einer stunde erst gab es diese
gewitter hier so zwischen den
niederrhein und dem bodensee und dann
brodelte es dahinter am nachmittag
kräftig weiter es gab auch hagel und
sturmböen den äußersten nordosten haben
die gewitter bislang noch nicht erreicht
das könnte sich in der nacht aber ändern
im südlichen brandenburg oder auch
richtung berlin sind durchaus schauer
und gewitter möglich den äußersten
nordosten werden die gewitter aber wohl
nicht erreichen das liegt auch am ost
sind der so ein bisschen dagegen drückt
hinter den gewittern da lockert es zum
teil auch auf und dann kann es an der
mosel zum beispiel etwas nebel geben die
tiefsttemperaturen heute nacht liegen
zwischen 15 und 9 grad und morgen
steigen sie dann wieder im westen und im
süden auf 23 bis 28 grad an der küste
aber auch im nordosten bleibt es kühler
mit werten von 16 bis 23 grad und auch
morgen vormittag haben wir es noch mit
schauern und gewittern zu tun die im
laufe des nachmittags dann aber weiter
richtung südosten abziehen und dann
könnte an der ostsee auch mal wieder die
sonne zum vorschein kommen deutlich
freundlicher ist es morgen hier im
südwesten da wechseln sonne und wolken
freundlich miteinander ab und ähnlich
sonniges wetter freundliches wetter gibt
es morgen auch in der schweiz am
nachmittag dann aber in den bergen kann
es doch für einige gewitter reichen und
die temperaturen steigen zum teil bis 29
grad deutlich kühler bleibt es immer
enger die bei 18 grad in österreich gibt
es auf der alpennordseite kräftige
schauer und gewitter auf der
alpensüdseite ist es freundlicher der
mittwoch wird in mitteleuropa sehr
sonnig bei temperaturen bis 31 grad aber
schon am donnerstag wird es dann von
südwesten wieder schwül warm und
gewittrig und her geht es weiter mit der
kulturzeit